what's going on honey  it's the third time you've been  suspended for fighting  i know you think i'd be better at it by  now i don't understand you dad would i  miss him too you know  [Applause]  but son you need to think about your  future  because it's coming  [Music]  [Applause]  sooner than you think  [Music]  whoa  i don't think we should be out here  take it easy  or  you know fall down and scream  you know how to get in my dad's garage  [Music]  you know how close the fridge  we have the same scar  right here  and you're wearing my dad's watch  [Music]  that's classified but yes  that once was  where are you going  time travel exists  this world  our world everything has already been  changed  that's why we're gonna put the genie  back in the bottle  adam dad  dad  that was awesome  okay grab onto that railing hold on for  dear life and try not to pass out from  the g's okay hey what's a guy  [Music]  you